>>> IT'S BEEN NEARLY THREE WEEKS
SINCE THE ASSASSINATION OF
HAITI'S PRESIDENT IN HIS HOME.
EVER SINCE, THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF UNANSWERS QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION.
TONIGHT IN A CNN EXCLUSIVE
REPORT, YOU'LL SEE HOW THOSE WHO
SHOULD BE GRANTED ACCESS TO THE
SEEN HAS BEEN KEPT AWAY AND EVEN
RECEIVED DEATH THREATS.
THE STORY FROM MATT RIVERS.
>> CNN HAS OBTAINED A COPY OF A
PREVIOUSLY UNSEEN FORMAL
COMPLAINT FILED WITH HAITI'S
NATIONAL POLICE IN WHICH SEVERAL
HAITIAN COURT CLERKS, KEY
FIGURES IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS, DETAIL THE DEATH
THREATS THEY HAVE RECEIVED IN
THE PAST FEW WEEKS.
HEY, CLERK, YOU CAN WAIT FOR A
BULLET IN YOUR HEAD.
THEY GAVE YOU AN ORDER AND YOU
KEEP DOING [ BLEEP ], READ ONE
TEXT MESSAGE.
THE THREAT COMES FROM SOMEONE
ANONYMOUS, ANGRY THAT THE CLERK
HAS NOT FOLLOWED CERTAIN
INSTRUCTIONS ABOUT WHOM AND WHAT
TO INVESTIGATE.
>> THE THREATS APPEAR TO BE JUST
ONE STARTLING EXAMPLE OF WHAT
APPEAR TO BE CONSISTENT PATTERNS
OF INTIMIDATION AND A FAILURE TO
FOLLOW PROCEDURE THROUGHOUT THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
PRESIDENT'S DEATH.
CNN HAS SPOKEN TO MULTIPLE
SOURCES CLOSE TO THE
INVESTIGATION WHO DETAILED WHAT
THEY BELIEVE ARE CLEAR ATTEMPTS
TO BLOCK INVESTIGATORS AND
THEREFORE THE PUBLIC FROM
FINDING OUT MORE ABOUT WHO
KILLED THE PRESIDENT AND WHY.
STARTING JUST A FEW HOURS AFTER
THE ASSASSINATION, AROUND 7:00
A.M. OUTSIDE THE PRESIDENTIAL
RESIDENCE.
SOURCES TELL CNN MULTIPLE COURT
CLERKS WERE KEPT OUTSIDE A
POLICE PERIMETER FOR MORE THAN
THREE HOURS AFTER ARRIVING, EVEN
WHILE OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
INSIDE.
NORMALLY, EXPERTS ON HAITI'S
LEGAL SYSTEM SAY, CLERKS ENTER A
CRIME SCENE RIGHT AWAY TO
OFFICIALLY DOCUMENT ANY EVIDENCE
AND TO TAKE STATEMENTS FROM KEY
WITNESSES, PER HAITIAN LAW.
>> IT'S UNCLEAR WHY IN THIS CASE
THEY WERE DELAYED.
WHEN THEY EVENTUALLY DID MAKE IT
INTO THE PRESIDENTIAL RESIDENCE
JUST DOWN THE STREET BEHIND ME,
SOURCES TELL US NOT ONE OF THE
ROUGHLY TWO DOZEN OR SO GUARDS
PRESENT AT THE TIME OF THE
ASSASSINATION WERE STILL THERE,
MEANING NO WITNESS STATEMENTS
WERE IMMEDIATELY TAKEN.
LATER ON THAT DAY, THERE WAS A
FIERCE GUN FIGHT BETWEEN HAITIAN
SECURITY FORCES AND SOME OF THE
ALLEGED ASSASSINS AT THIS
BUILDING.
MULTIPLE SUSPECTS WERE KILLED,
ALL OF WHOM WERE COLOMBIAN.
SOURCES CLOSE TO THE
INVESTIGATION TELL US COURT
CLERKS WERE NOT IMMEDIATELY
ALLOWED INTO THE SHOOTOUT SCENE,
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN FILLED
WITH EVIDENCE, INCLUDING WE'RE
TOLD, THE BODIES OF THE DEAD
COLOMBIANS.
IN AN OFFICIAL DOCUMENT FILED
WITH HAITI'S TOP PROSECUTOR,
CLERKS DESCRIBE EXAMINING THE
BODIES NOT HERE AT THE SHOOTOUT
SITE BUT HERE, OUTSIDE OF AN
OFFICE BUILDING JUST DOWN THE
ROAD.
THAT SUGGESTS THE BODIES HAD
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE CRIME
SCENE BEFORE BEING PROCESSED.
NO OFFICIAL EXPLANATION OF WHY
THAT HAPPENED WAS GIVEN.
>> WHERE IS THE LEADERSHIP OF
HAITI?
>> A FEW DAYS LATER, AUTHORITIES
START TO ZERO IN ON THIS MAN, AS
SOMEONE WHO ALLEGEDLY RECRUITED
AND HELPED ORGANIZE SOME OF
THESE MEN SEEN HERE, THE LARGE
GROUP OF COLOMBIANS AND SEVERAL
AMERICANS HAITIAN OFFICIALS
ALLEGE CARRIED OUT THIS CRIME.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THEM
PUBLICLY.
A SOURCE CLOSE TO THE
INVESTIGATION PREVIOUSLY TOLD
CNN SOMEONE TOLD INVESTIGATORS
HE IS INNOCENT.
IT WAS AROUND THIS TIME THAT THE
ANONYMOUS PHONE CALLS STARTED.
ACCORDING TO THE OFFICIAL
COMPLAINT FILED WITH POLICE
OBTAINED BY "CNN NEWSROOM,"
CLERKS RECEIVED MULTIPLE
THREATENING PHONE CALLS TELLING
THEM TO STOP INVESTIGATING TWO
SUSPECTS IN THE CASE AND REMOVE
THEM FROM THEIR REPORTS.
ACCORDING TO THE COMPLAINT, THE
CALLS WERE FOLLOWED BY THIS TEXT
MESSAGE.
QUOTE, THEY TOLD YOU TO STOP
GOING AROUND SEARCHING PEOPLE'S
HOUSES AND THE PRESIDENT
ASSASSINATION CASE, AND YOU
REFUSED.
YOU HAVE BEEN TOLD TO TAKE OUT
TWO NAMES, AND YOU REFUSED.
WE'RE WATCHING YOU.
SOURCES CLOSE TO THE
INVESTIGATION TELL US THE CLERKS
WERE ALSO TOLD TO ADD UNRELATED
NAMES TO THEIR REPORTS, PEOPLE
WHO HAD NO CLEAR CONNECTION TO
THE CRIME.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHO MADE ANY OF THE
CALLS OR SENT THE TEXT MESSAGES.
THEN THERE'S WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE FBI.
SPECIAL AGENTS FROM THE BUREAU
INVITED IN BY HAITI'S GOVERNMENT
WENT TO THE PRESIDENTIAL
RESIDENCE ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO TO
COLLECT EVIDENCE.
SOURCES TELL US THE AGENTS
MANAGED TO FIND A LOT, INCLUDING
THE MEGA PHONE USED HERE.
>> EVERYBODY BACK UP.
>> THIS IS FROM THE NIGHT OF THE
ASSASSINATION, WHERE ONE OF THE
SUSPECTS IS KEEPING PEOPLE AWAY
FROM THE SCENE BY CLAIMING IT
WAS ALL A DEA OPERATION,
SOMETHING THE AGENCY AND HAITIAN
OFFICIALS REPEATEDLY DENIED THAT
IT WAS.
SOURCES TELL CNN FBI AGENTS WERE
A LITTLE SURPRISED TO FIND SO
MUCH EVIDENCE STILL AT THE CRIME
SCENE AND LEFT WONDERING WHY
HAITIAN AUTHORITIES HADN'T
ALREADY COLLECTED IT.
THE SOURCES ADDED THEY DO EXPECT
THE FBI WILL HAVE CONTINUED
ACCESS TO EVIDENCE THAT THEY
REQUESTED.
>> AND MATT RIVERS JOINS US NOW.
HAVE AUTHORITIES COMMENTED ABOUT
THE DEATH THREATS?
>> WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO
MULTIPLE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES,
ANDERSON.
ONLY ONE PERSON GOT BACKTUSE,
HAITI'S TOP PROSECUTOR WHO WOULD
ONLY SAY HE WOULD TRY TO IMPROVE
THE SECURITY FOR SOME OF THESE
INVESTIGATORS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR WEEKS
NOW.
EVEN AFTER ALL THAT REPORTING WE
LAID OUT, WHAT DON'T WE HAVE?
A MOTIVE FOR THE REASON WHY THE
PRESIDENT WAS KILLED, A
MASTERMIND BEHIND THAT
OPERATION.
WHAT WE DO HAVE IS WHAT VERY
MUCH APPEARS TO BE